[Música]
cuántas personas es una preguntita
rápida cuántas personas se han sentido
en algún punto de su vida que no encajan
que no se sienten parte de un grupo que
no encajen con una persona les doy unos
15 segundos para que reflexionen sobre
eso mientras me pongo un rato
bueno mientras estaban reflexionando
todo lo que ustedes se dieron cuenta de
si alguna vez se sintieron así fue toda
mi secundaria siempre fui el qué
al que criticaban al que se burlaban al
que era un objeto de burla
y sinceramente nunca me importó pero
nunca me sentí con la confianza de
acercarme a alguien a tratar de hacer
algo más que siempre ser un simple
estudiante por lo mismo para que se me
van a criticar entonces así lo deje
cuando entré al betis vi que mucha gente
traía cubos de rubik
no sé hasta se me hace muy interesante y
hasta cierto punto atractivo el por qué
lo traían pero por la misma vergüenza
que trae arrastrando pues jamás me
acerque a preguntar oa tratar de hacer
algo con eso
un día pasaron por los salones invitando
a un torneo que iba a verlas en cada
semestre y coincidió que iba a ser el de
ese semestre
y pues me quedo en un horario muy padre
entonces dije pues porque no voy y veo
qué onda y de verdad me enamoré o sea
entre y me enamoré completamente esta
sensación esa experiencia esa emoción
que tienen los chavos
al hacer un buen tiempo un mal tiempo al
ganarle a su amigo que está en silla de
perder contra él y esa bonita sensación
de competencia que ahorita ya casi
ningún deporte te da ya todo es más por
negocio entonces eso me gustó muchísimo
ese mismo día un amigo traía un cubo un
amigo un compañero ahí del salón
y por la misma yo creo por la misma
euforia del torneo de la misma emoción
dije pues porque no quiero me puede
decir que no
se lo voy a pedir y efectivamente me
dijo que no me deja prestar total así
que no le hable durante muchísimo tiempo
saliendo de que ese día de clases le
pedí este año marque si podemos llegar
una importación compre uno de esos de de
15 pesos de esos que quieran horrible
pero pues me servía para aprender
en un fin de semana aprendí a resolverlo
pero pues era padre y recordaba mucho de
ese torneo toda la emoción toda la gente
y pues me motivaba a seguir aprendiendo
seguir aprendiendo pasó el tiempo y mis
papás era como que ya suelta el cubo y
salía a donde fuera iba a la tienda iba
con mi cubo
varias veces me tropecé por andar con el
cubo y éste no salía sin él
mis papás ya se empezaron a dar cuenta
que era algo que iba en serio que yo
quería dedicarme a esto y entonces como
hasta ahora lo siguen haciendo me
apoyaron en todo
entonces al final
no empecé a bajar mis tiempos empecé a
mejorar empecé a conocer gente que tenía
ese mismo gusto por esta cosa rara
fui a mi primer torneo oficial el primer
torneo grande el primer torneo donde
venía gente de todo el país fue en plaza
del sol en fashion
y de verdad ha sido la experiencia más
bonita que he tenido en toda mi vida
toda esa sensación lo que les decía de
la competencia a todo estar toda la
gente empujando se para ver que
estábamos haciendo emocionándose junto a
nosotros sin saber ni siquiera de armar
un cubo ni siquiera haberlo girado en
alguna vez en su vida los balcones de la
plaza del sol tiernos
s hay algo curioso ahí en plaza del sol
nos prestaron el espacio pero nos
dijeron se van hasta el rincón entrando
a la izquierda y adonde estaban antes
los juguetes de niños ahí nos mandaron
y fue victorioso porque al siguiente año
nos pusieron en el centro se fue tanta
la gente que fue tanto éxito el que tuvo
que nos pusieron al menos en trabajo en
las cálidas eléctricas
entonces
en resumen
en este torneo conocí a una chava se me
hacía muy linda pero por lo mismo de mi
inseguridad y mi vergüenza en jamás le
hablé para que me iba a ignorar
completamente
en resumen
este chavo que me
que me negó alguna vez su culo
es mi mejor amigo ahora somos mejores
amigos damos clases en el cebetis he
dado clases en preparatoria ya están
entrevistas de radio y esta chava que me
gustó hoy es mi novia entonces y por qué
o sea porque estoy aquí hablando con
ustedes porque tengo esta oportunidad
porque he crecido tanto personalmente es
socialmente amorosamente porque me
dediqué
a hacer lo que me gustaba encontré algo
que me gustó y me dediqué de lleno a eso
entonces
los invito independientemente de lo que
les guste yo sé que a quien le va a
gustar eso pero independientemente el
sueño que tenga la pasión que tenga
síganlo
su vida va a cambiar completamente
y además de eso lo importante es que van
a ser felices
y de eso de eso se trata la vida muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]